a woman arrives at her new workplace a
school which looks very Bleak and empty
this is her first day teaching in this
school and she has a hard time searching
for her designated Class 4E but with the
help of a student she eventually finds
it the class consists of a bunch of
noisy and arrogant students however she
ignores all of it and starts teaching
just like she has done all her life and
in a matter of days she starts getting
used to the students however one day
when she chats with another teacher she
learns the Class 4E which she has been
teaching doesn't exist scared the woman
rushes to the place and finds that the
teacher was right the class is empty and
it appears as if it has been like that
for years the woman is Jennifer and a
few days earlier she is seen on her way
to the school in a cab it is her first
day and she is both excited and nervous
about it when she arrives at the
premises it's already raining heavily
and the large school looks desolate and
empty Jennifer tries asking a few
students for directions to the staff
room but all of them ignore her then she
wanders around the school until she
meets a student named don don who is
playing basketball all by herself
Jennifer introduces herself as a
substitute teacher while dondon explains
that it's lunch time and that's why
everyone is out she then takes her to
the staff room and leaves inside the
staff room Jennifer meets Miss Kong the
student officer of the school has the
tour chatting the principal Miss Wang
arrives and assigns Jennifer as a
substitute teacher for an afternoon
class she reveals that the history
teacher is on maternity leave and will
be absent for a few months Jennifer
gladly accepts the afternoon slot as she
wants to get over her recent breakup
then she departs after confirming that
she will start from the next day however
the next afternoon when Jennifer goes to
school she finds the staff room empty
instead she finds a note on the table by
Miss Kong stating that she has been
assigned to Class 4E she has also
mentioned that the students of that
class are quite mischievous and warns
her to be careful however Jennifer is so
motivated that she doesn't mind taking
on any kind of students she soon
Ventures upstairs to look for the 4E
class but strangely it is nowhere the
weird thing is that there are still no
students in the school despite it not
being lunchtime just then she comes
across the same girl from earlier Don
Don and again asks for help Don Don who
happens to study in the same class takes
the new teacher with her when they
arrive at 4E Jennifer notes that the
class looks more like a fish market than
a classroom some students are quarreling
some are riding on the board While
others are just hurling profanities
nobody's selling fish though so it's a
lose-lose ignoring all this she
introduces herself and starts to talk
about the importance of history but
everyone ignores her they are simply
interested in chatting and having fun
Jennifer realizes that Miss Kong was
right about this class and decides to
change her teaching strategy a bit she
promises to bring historical movies the
next day so that everyone can learn in a
fun way but still no one except don don
pays attention to a word she is saying
to make matters worse some arrogant boys
even pass derogatory comments on her
despite all this Jennifer keeps her calm
and continues with the class later that
he evening as Jennifer is strolling
around the busy Market she discovers
that some of her students are involved
in adultery they are taking dondon who
looks scared with them for the first
time Jennifer confronts them in front of
their customers causing all of them to
run away however she manages to catch
one named Carol and gives her a serious
lecture but surprisingly instead of
being sorry Carol tells her to mind her
own business before walking away when
Jennifer is about to reach home her
ex-boyfriend Chung is seen waiting for
her he begs her to give him a chance but
she replies that she has already given
him multiple chances in the last three
years to make things work however the
stubborn man keeps on insisting and even
gets on his knees to convince her which
causes quite a stir in the area honey
look at that simp but fortunately before
things can escalate Jennifer's Father
Abraham arrives and pulls away his
daughter before he leaves he also warns
Chung that he will call the cops if he
gets anywhere near his daughter again
after reaching home Jennifer shares the
incident with her mother Jen and breaks
down it turns out that Chung used to get
severely drunk and assault her this
continued for several years and it is
also the reason why Jennifer couldn't
work Jen consoles her daughter by saying
that she should forget about the past
and make a new start the new job at the
school is the perfect opportunity for
her just then Abraham enters the room
and tells Jennifer that she should not
be soft-hearted if Chung runs into her
again the next day at school Jennifer
tries to take control of the class but
once again she fails miserably she is
also worried about Don Don who appears
to be absent after the class is over she
asks Carol about Don Don but her male
friends interrupt and threaten Jennifer
to keep her mouth shut about last
night's incident and stop being so nosy
shortly after Jennifer finds dondon
entering the restroom and follows her
surprisingly all the restroom stalls are
empty it appears as if the girl has
vanished Into Thin Air disregarding this
Jennifer tries to go outside but finds
the door locked scared she cries for
help but nobody can hear her suddenly
strange paranormal activities start
occurring the restroom stalls start to
slam on their own water bursts from the
Taps and a Fan's blade flies smashing
all the mirrors and almost hitting her
as Jennifer watches in horror and
disbelief Blood starts dripping from the
ceiling which shows a strange figure
several hours have passed by and when
Jennifer doesn't return home her worried
Father Abraham informs the cops they
immediately Trace her cell phone and
find out that it's inside the school the
cops and Abraham search every corner of
the place and eventually find her in the
corner of the bathroom Frozen in fear as
they turn on the lights Jennifer
realizes that everything looks normal
she then starts panicking and wishes to
go home the next morning as Jennifer
rests in her room her concerned parents
believe that she's going through an
emotional crisis and suggests that she
takes some time off from work however
just a few minutes later Jennifer
receives a call from Miss Kong who asks
her to join work from the next day
claiming that there's no one to teach
the students Jennifer is hesitant at
first but since she has nothing much to
do she agrees in the next scene at
school Jennifer is chatting with Miss
Kong during the lunch break she inquires
about why the students of 40 are so
mischievous and hearing this Miss Kong
suddenly turns pale she reveals that no
such class exists in the school and that
Jennifer had been assigned another class
as expected Jennifer doesn't believe
this as she has been interacting with
the students and knows them pretty well
to verify her claims she takes Miss Kong
to the class but upon reaching it she
has taken aback to find it abandoned it
seems more like a storeroom than a
classroom or a fish market the site
makes Jennifer panic and this is when
principal Wang arrives and reveals
everything 20 years ago there was a
Class 4E in the school which had a lot
of students however one particular
student was always bullied and tormented
by the others fed up with everything one
day the student brought a petrol
canister to the classroom and burnt the
whole place down which took the lives of
14 people among them were two teachers
who desperately tried to save the
students but all in vain because of the
incident the school gained a bad
reputation that's why Class 4E was
canceled Forever After hearing the story
Jennifer is still left in shock as she
cannot comprehend how she could see the
students to calm her down the principal
assigns her a new class 2A which
apparently has the best students in the
school when Jennifer learns that the
class is conducted exclusively in the
morning she agrees to take it on the way
home Jennifer is again stopped by Chung
he consistently insists that she give
him a chance but once again she ignores
him suddenly she sees dondon with some
bruises on her face but before she can
ask anything this scared teenager warns
her to not go back to school before
running away afterwards when Jennifer
reaches home she finds her parents along
with some parishioners praying for her
the next day Jennifer ignores all the
warnings and heads to school when she
enters the new class 2A she is shocked
to see the same students from the
supposed non-existent class terrified
she tries to run away but some boys
block the door and insist that she teach
ghosts need to know math too Jennifer
assumes it's all her imagination and
proceeds to write on the board but
suddenly some students turn into ghosts
one of them lashes her with long
splitted tongue while some fly and
approach her but as soon as Jennifer
turns around everyone reverts back to
normal just then Jennifer spots dawned
on signaling her to go so she opens the
door and gets out of the school as fast
as she can that evening before reaching
home she again runs into dandon who
pleads with her to never return to the
school when Jennifer asks why the girl
reveals that the other students are
trying to kill her saying this much she
leaves a few steps further Jennifer
finds Chung waiting for her and attempts
to ignore him however he stops her and
shows her a recording of a few minutes
earlier where she is talking to the air
turns out that dondon is also a ghost
who would have thought as Jennifer
becomes frightened Chung worries about
her and takes her to meet an exorcist
called the master he tells Jennifer that
the School is Haunted and gives her a
magical dagger to use against the
spirits in Desperate Times afterwards
when Jennifer gets back home she finds
that her parents are out for the night
just then she gets a call on the
landline from one of the Haunted
students who teases her that there is
nowhere to run Jennifer panics and
disconnects the call but soon her mobile
phone starts ringing the spirit on the
other end tells her to embrace whatever
is coming for her suddenly the lights
start to Flicker and strange noises and
creatures pop up from her phone panicked
she takes out the magical dagger and
stabs her phone causing everything to
come to a halt the next morning Jennifer
gets a call from her mother Jen on her
neighbor's phone since hers is damaged
Jen mentions that she has arrived at her
school as per her daughter's
instructions and now she is accompanied
by two students from Class 4E one of
them is Carol who takes the phone and
asks Jennifer to come save her mother
quickly wasting no time Jennifer rushes
to the school and finds the students in
their Spirit forms they have placed Jen
on the edge of the window ready to push
her down just then Carol asks Jennifer
whether she wants to save her mother or
herself Jennifer replies both like a
badass and takes out the a magical
dagger which emits a light strong enough
to temporarily blind the spirits sadly
one of them pushes Jen from the window
killing her instantly wow that backfired
when Jennifer sees her mother's lifeless
body on the ground she becomes enraged
and starts stabbing the spirits one by
one with the dagger a student who looks
normal begs Jennifer not to kill her but
she stabs her anyway later the police
arrive at the scene and capture Jennifer
who looks like a total psychopath now
her distraught parents also arrive
revealing that Jen is still alive it
turns out that she never went to the
school as Jennifer watches in shock the
chief policeman explains that she is
brutally killed 14 students from the 4E
classroom just then a man arrives at the
scene claiming to be the Principal
Jennifer asserts that the man is lying
as the principle is Miss Wang she hired
him a week ago and revealed about the
incident that took place 20 years ago
hearing this the actual principle of the
school tells the cops about the incident
that transpired 20 years ago he mentions
that since everyone was terrified of
this Story the school had to hide the
memorial pictures of the 14 people who
perished in the fire he then moves a
cupboard and uncovers the pictures which
shows the students from The Haunted
class and the two teachers the teachers
are revealed to be none other than
principal Wang and Miss Kong moreover it
is revealed that Jennifer killed the
students with a screwdriver which she
thought was a magical dagger the same
screwdriver that her ex-boyfriend Shang
used to commit the unthinkable the day
before yesterday this means that she
never met the real Chung but only his
Spirit hearing all of this Jennifer
starts laughing like a maniac forcing
the police to take her away as she sits
in the police van she sees don don
outside dribbling her basketball which
is actually Chung's head subscribe for
more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching